welcome back to new rockstars one
division is giving us
nightmares ambition as a corpse how
dead is this synthesized exactly and is
wanda a grave robber who samples the
product
i'm eric boss this is rogue theory with
me today
is inside marvel co-host jessica clemons
that was
filthy how dare you i don't know what
you're talking about
you right into interpretation of sample
that was not in my head okay whatever
yeah
okay whatever you infer what you infer
i'll imply what i imply
it was sex it was sex
okay we're not even we're not even gonna
get into this not king shaming but
actually king shaming because you
shouldn't have sex with like
uh yeah no no necrophilia is something
we can shame i think
oh yes yes yes but you know we are going
to get into our other guests today
one of our favorite returning guests
writer laura siricool
hi i like how a transition from
nicophilia to
hey now it's laura you're making it
connect again we're just making gross
connections that i'm not saying
explicitly but you know
through a recent bias and now to our
next guest
speaking of uh uh dead body
bangers here's uh no um some of this
might be cut from the episode
leave that in leave that in well uh
we're also thrilled to welcome a first
time guest on new rockstars but a long
time
friend of the show chris mcgowan hey
chris hi eric thanks for having me
and uh what if everyone's dead is it
still necrophilia that'll be my theory
oh
like blind leading the blind it's dead
we are gonna answer all these questions
this episode of rogue theory because we
are now
halfway through these monovision
episodes and as the walls of west view
are coming
crumbling down vision underneath this
facade as wanda's sitcom husband
is actually a terrifying gray corpse
with a big old hole in his head from
when thanos ripped out the mind stone in
infinity war
now uh we have seen vision trying to
push through the west view border
but on the outside he reverts to corpse
form it looks like
a hole's back in his head and he is
posing on his knees just like the moment
wanda blew
up his stone in infinity war killing him
the first time so
what does it mean that wanda sees vision
as a corpse
does he always look this way under the
illusion are wanda's
eyes just plain tricks on her uh i want
to start this conversation by talking
about the
removed in-game post-credits scene that
paul bettany admitted to
in which vision's corpse would have been
rolled out of a morgue
drawer by wanda so does this mean that
in wandavision
did wanda personally exhume vision's
corpse
so um i think it's so fresh and then she
had to go into battle
with that frame of mind and so she was
like okay what do i do next
so i feel like the the body was there so
i feel like
she was able to because she has this
power
so i think she was able just to be able
to like transform it and bring it
somewhere else
like just transported that's uh i didn't
really think about that context the fact
that like for wanda it was just
uh the immediate next minute that she
saw she was holding
vision's corpse uh and then she comes
back and even his corpse is gone it's
like where did his corpse go i didn't
get a chance to bury him
and then like she sees thanos there in
her mind it's just the same thanos
uh so he's like i don't have no idea who
you are and she's like you will
uh a nice adjustment from her in that
moment because
she must have thought oh maybe he hit
his head on something and that's why he
forgot who i was
i want to hear from you other two what
do you think this looks like is it a
morgue that she's going into
is she in a graveyard with a shovel
somewhere i i vaguely remember this but
i think it was in
west coast avengers where he was
basically
captured and dismantled um and kind of
dissected by a bunch of like
people that was under king the conqueror
basically like he
put him under a spell that made them do
it but when i thought about i was like
oh when i saw
your theory about that being like what
is it is it the library
is it inside of her brain is it a morgue
and then hearing the clip of you being
like yeah he
she was supposed to like pull me out of
that what if they took pieces from that
west coast avengers and was like because
they're giving homage to every kind of
comic book
yeah like version of vision and wanda so
what if they did that homage of like
oh he was which i think i said at first
he wasn't i was like i disagree with
this idea but
what if he is being dissected or worked
upon and when she
finds the body that's when she like
starts one division
and that's why we're maybe when she
comes to she'll be in that room with
that corpse in the morgue
or the dissection lab probably under
sword
but we don't know but i was like what if
that's the case what if
so i guess essentially the same thing
like it's just the corpse there
in the middle and she just starts around
yeah so just like i'm trying to picture
this spatially
there's just a dead synthesized corpse
sitting in the middle of this real-life
new jersey town
but it's been all coated in this like
reality bubble
like what is physically happening to
vision right now is he being dragged
around like a rag doll
is he being puppeted around or is it
just like his presence
within that vicinity is enough for her
to like project his consciousness
like walking around and goofing around
sitcom style with her
i have a theory and they're starting to
kind of intersect so i'm sure that'll
they'll come out through this but um
vision is only alive
as everyone sees them correctly and fine
in that bubble
because wanda's energy is uh
kind of like a wireless uh charger so
while he's in the bubble her energy is
bringing him back
um and to where he was before i keep i
keep
thinking like sentient weapons sentient
weapon and vision to me
is a sentient weapon so what if sword
had a body
hey everybody vision's dead body is gone
and now they're like oh it's
it's here and like now these these kind
of forces are kind of coming together to
try to figure out
what happened i like that idea of a
portable charging station right like
basically he's um has his battery
removed when the mine stone was taken
out that's what made him die
in that moment because he's got all
kinds of components you know and they
were trying to basically bypass
vision's battery that's what sure he was
doing she was doing what like george
costanza was doing the frogger machine
and was just trying to keep it charged
uh so they wouldn't need this batter or
they wouldn't need
the charging port uh so is that what
wand is doing her power is to drive from
the mine stone is she trying
to be like an organ replacement as a as
a mind stone
source like she plugs into his brain uh
keeps him back on life support
but as soon as he unplugs from her he's
dead again
probably he's probably only exist in her
world too remember
agent wu went to visit a missing person
report
because it was a witness protection
program person i think that witness
protection program was part of some kind
of experimental thing
who has vision's body to work on and i
i feel like when she went you know and
sees his body like she just
went like something triggered her
remember she has the power to destroy
the vis the stone
so that means she has the power to
generate the stone so do you think that
missing person laura
is vision that like jimmy wu was just
kind of using some coding language that
he had some kind of like operation with
hayward
and sword and they were the missing
person was just this
entity that they were operating on that
went poof once it was brought to west
view
i think the missing person was agnes or
dottie who has the power
can it be a world where like the witness
isn't who we think it is
um is there a situation that play that
like
okay i know this is kind of going into
what we all think that possibly tyler's
at work on this and tyler is the bad guy
so what if there is a crime uh yeah so
what if there was something that sword
that like intercepted the fbi did wu
ever
actually physically meet this witness
person or was it always like
communicated virtually or remotely and
he never like talked to him face to face
i assume wu must have like made contact
with his witness like
based off of how fbi protocol works it's
like
they have like kind of a one-on-one uh
connection with this criminal informant
they relocate them i mean he did say
that he had talked to this person's
former associates right so
uh based on that i would assume he would
know who that person was
well he might if you talk to his former
associates doesn't mean you talk to him
i'm only making this idea because it's
like what if
he is someone what if the witness is
somewhat like
not saying it's mafesto not saying it's
my face
but i'm gonna say but i will say i will
say really quick what if what if
possibly like if
so turned himself into something else
and he's just doing that the entire time
so what if he does turn himself into the
witness and protection
and that's who wu sees him as um but
it's actually tyler heart or tyler
hayward
um this is for later but i'm just like
thinking of these scenarios of just like
what if like wu
is being deceived himself and i mean i'm
sure he is because he's fbi at sword now
just like
kind of running amok but
i there has to be a situation where wu
is wrong
who has to show up wrong i think wu is
being used at the very least i don't
think
jimmy was going to be part of a
conspiracy i think he's too much of a
good guy
um i mean he is uh john krasinski so you
can trust that face you know
when he's sitting across he's always
been working with you what are you
talking about
he's the john krasinski yeah yes and
it's not just any agent it's agent wu
who is familiar with scrolls like as as
you all have discussed
it's not like you know agent uh joe
schmo he knows what's going on
so it's very particular and specific
that he was assigned to this case
that is yeah yeah i think uh
like when you have someone in witness
protection the you know your high
the higher ups at the fbi have to
approve that you know um
and uh there has to be some kind of like
uh
thumbs up some check mark on that i feel
like
uh the acting director of sword might
have been able to pull some strings to
get that person relocated that's why i
think hayward
the fact that these were introduced back
to back that hayward knew about this
but didn't know enough like why would he
send someone to an fbi whitney with
just someone to operate a little remote
control drone like anybody can do that
like that's it's ridiculous that she was
sent there obviously there's something
there
but like getting back to vision uh so do
we think like how long
could he last outside of west view like
is he
going to like stay dead as soon as this
girard
is over well uh or we've seen the last
division
so shuri never finished her work right
so there isn't a fake
stone that he can wanda could use right
yeah not a fake stone and i don't think
yeah i assure you was interrupted by
corvus glaive who got in there she did
close a couple files you know just like
no i'm just looking at porn and then it
all closed and who knows how much
progress she made
uh but it sounds like she didn't get him
completely downloaded because
you know thinking about this i think
wanda even as powerful she is she knows
this isn't gonna last forever like
someone's gonna get in there
she knows her fellow avengers somebody
so she's trying to
run out the clock and do whatever she's
doing in my mind making an artificial
battery so maybe she doesn't have
shuri's designs maybe she's like maybe i
can do something
to make this last beyond the bubble and
then i'll just like you know kind of
make everyone forget and run away with
vision
oh i like just too many hands in the pot
the situation because wand is trying to
save it sword's trying to save it
fbi is trying to say it monica's trying
to figure out yeah
i could see that that's a good idea um
but this idea that okay so now we know
that vision is dead
uh based off of the sword um dry erase
board when they were id and everyone
right
like the people with valid new jersey
driver's license i think we can assume
are
alive but it's weird because like where
are their bodies
like how do they get their driver's
license if like their bodies are inside
west view like are their bodies
somewhere else or are their homes
somewhere else like
did they pull uh those looked like their
actual ids or did they just print off
their ids
and then click them out to look like ids
like we know the last three videos you
rented
online uh eric voss and we know
sure i mean they can pull they can pull
a print out but why would they cut them
out to look like id shaped it's just
weird that i assume those are the right
directors are impeccable but they don't
think about the logic of it
yeah there's an eager admin assistant
who's like i'm this is my chance to
shine i'm going to make these ids look
just like ids
and it's going to be on the board and
they're going to say i did it you know i
would put in latex i would
straight up do it i would like do a
laminated
like these new jerseys
here's what it is guys we figured out
they're sending in all those drones
those drones are
z and they go into people's house and
they lift their wallets out of their
back pockets
and they take out their new jersey ids
and they fly
back to uh sword hq and they're like
thanks drone
and then they that's all the black
mirror episode
everyone can't find their id when
they're buying alcohol everyone's like
where's my
id we got another tangent we gotta take
it but it's a valid question
i'll do a whole video about it it's not
a valid question
how did they get their ideas
i hope they punched a hole in the other
one you yourself in one of your theories
were like look at that guy in the back
who's excited to just watch the tv and
be there
that was his doing yeah this is the guy
i related with
this is great yeah he had that smile
because he's like wait till they see the
work ideas
but my point for bringing up the ids was
the fact that
uh these are living people if their ids
are still
there i think we can make that
assumption that these people are all
still alive otherwise why would swords
say like oh
they're we're worried about getting
these people out but
no id for agnes and we know from the
trailer where she told vision
am i dead and he's like no why would you
say that and she's like as you are
like is she dead too are we going to see
a corpse catherine han
no because she's a witch and she's
amazing the witches never die
no of course they don't what kind of
question is that
what a waste of kathryn hahn she's
amazing also yeah catherine
that's a waste of catherine hunt damn
straight that would
they i would sue them hey maybe that is
it like
she when she said am i dead maybe she
was like almost killed
like she was burnt at salem or something
like that because we know her
anniversary with ralph is when the salem
trials began june 2nd maybe she was
burned but like she keeps getting
reincarnated in these different forms
because she is a witch she is
supernatural
and she's never really sure whether
she's alive or dead because once you
become immortal what's the difference
could could she also be i know i know
agnes the witch is very popular theory
but could she be uh an embodiment of the
mind stone
much like ghost red skull was could she
be like
you need me wanda to do this so here i
am as a
as as your neighbor no chris
no i'm kidding chris i actually think
that that could be accurate uh
in the way that i think all of these
characters are being painted uh
and projected by mine stone derived
radiation
uh at the end of the day i think the
fact that they call this radiation they
call it cmbr
i think it's all really coming from the
fact that she got her powers in the mind
stone that's her link that's her
physical link with vision that he was
powered from the mind
stone and somehow that same radiation is
what is causing these people to look the
way they look
in west view so i think both of us could
be right
but uh only i am right when it comes to
the weirdest ideas
like this driver's license you know
who's right it's weird
how do they get them they can't just
print this out
oh my god people in the comments are
gonna be like of course they can they're
just sword
they're gonna be like i work at a dmv we
print out so many copies of your ids and
we use it to get liquor
i don't know why they don't understand
they could buy their own liquor uh
anyway well of the ideas i heard because
hey by the way this may seem like a
conversation but this is in my brain and
i
am constantly awarding and subtracting
points from people whenever i talk to
them
i'm not gonna tell you my my code or my
algorithm it's too hard to explain and
if i did
your head would explode um but instead i
will say
one of you is gonna get a golden sparkle
buck
uh for your take so the golden sparkle
book is gonna go to
chris mcgowan for his portable charging
station
theory rudest thing like the most shade
and also a good
a good theory that vision is just a
walking
plug-in
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
that so rude
that's great if i was vision i'd be like
wow that's why it gets mad the next
episode yeah
all right we're gonna theorize about the
possible dark motivations of the
director of sword and what really
sword is doing in this show but first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode starting
with our friends at caliper cbd so this
episode is brought to you by caliper cbd
and their cbd powder that helps you feel
better without making drastic changes to
your routine
their 20 milligram packets of cbd powder
are completely flavorless they mix
easily into
any food or drink bring them on the road
with you or take them to work
where every youth might need a little
calming cbd influence in your life
they have been really great for my sleep
and other members of the new rockstar
staff
really like them for easing soreness and
stress caliper cbd comes in affordable
and 60 count packs individual packets
give you the benefits of cbd wherever
you go
caliper is completely thc free really
all the goodness of cbd
but you're not going to get high from
doing it uh that's why we're okay saying
take it on the road
if you could get up for that there are
kids watching
it's clinically proven that you can
absorb 450 percent more cbd with caliper
cbd powder compared to tinctures 450
that's a lot of percent get 20 off your
first order when you use promo code
rogue at tricaliper.com
rogue you can try caliper cbd risk-free
for 30 days
if you don't love it they'll give you a
full refund that's
tricaliper.com rogue don't forget that
promo code rogue for 20 off your first
order we also want to thank our friends
at helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode
i've been losing sleep running through
the mephisto theories in my head and
also seeing mephisto when i look up at
the the ceiling corner he's just kind of
like
clutching himself in there like you know
the insidious demon
um he's there he's everywhere he's
laughing at me in the corner right now
but he's also i think right behind me
um so you can tell why i'm having sleep
trouble but
i have not been losing sleep because of
a bad mattress i have a great mattress
you know where i got that mattress helix
sleep
i have a personalized mattress from
helix sleep they shipped it
straight to my door with free no contact
delivery free returns and a 100 night
sleep trial
helix made a sleep quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress
for you i took the quiz i was matched to
i think it's the dusk
looks helix mattress because i wanted
like a medium to firm mattress
but with lumbar support and they hooked
me up it's exactly it's like the perfect
one for me
i love helix but you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq
wired magazine apartment therapy just go
to helixlev.com
rogue theory take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you're gonna love it
helix is offering up to
two hundred dollars off all mattress
orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com
rogue theory and finally new rockstars
is excited to be partnering with
the app stereo on three new weekly live
shows we just finished our first week of
these shows they were super fun
we heard from a lot of you and we were
actually in the top 20
shows on the app that's exciting all
three shows are live on the stereo app
you listen to us talking in real time
you can send us audio voicemails we'll
play it we'll respond to it
you can call us out when i mispronounce
something or say that um jimi hendrix
was from the bay area as opposed to from
washington state
uh you can correct me in real time yeah
i know that now i'm an idiot
um you can download this app for free at
stereo.com
new rockstars and if you download using
that link you will automatically follow
us and be notified about all of our new
shows whenever we go live
uh so yeah with stereo you interact with
us in real time we submit these
voicemails we're going to play during
the shows we're going to answer your
questions react to your theories
uh and these are our new stereo
exclusive shows
so one is one that jessica and i did
last friday it's an expanded interactive
version of our
inside marvel one division after show
that's every friday morning at 8 00 a.m
that doesn't replace or delay anything
else we're doing
where we are uh doing this show and then
you're gonna see the video version
normal time uh friday afternoon but if
you want to get it early and get those
fresh hot takes
fresh in the morning with your hot bagel
you gotta find us 8 a.m pacific time
on stereo but also there's new rock
stars news that's with me and phillip
molina reacting to the biggest nerdy
headlines of the week and answering your
questions that's every wednesday at 1pm
pacific
and then uh i think my favorite of the
three our editors show
that comes out monday mornings at 8 a.m
pacific
with our editors john and josh who are
giving you like a peek behind the scenes
at new rockstars telling you all the
dirty secrets we don't want you to know
reacting to the comments and the videos
of the week that came out on the channel
uh and just kind of giving you yeah
basically what really is happening at
new rockstars
that i can't tell you about because uh i
i have too much shame
so access these live shows submit your
voicemail questions and theories and
interact with us in real time by
downloading the free stereo app at
stereo dot com new rockstars at stereo
dot com slash new rockstars all right
let's get back to wanda vision so
the word we have learned is currently
being run by
action director tyler hayward this guy
got promoted to the position during the
blip
when the job was probably gonna go to
monica rambo after her mother's death
her mother's cancer returned right in
the middle of the blip
and according to monica tyler was the
only person for the job which i felt was
kind of an insult
he's like uh oh wait did he say i was
the only one for the job or did she say
you're the only one yeah he said it he
said it
okay so it wasn't an insult it was he
was just trying to be like no i guess i
was the only one who could do it
um he was like kind of an insult still
it's like a little shade
of like self-shape you're the only one
that can do it but i'm
in it so in monica's absence
a lot has been going on at sword we got
missing astronauts
they're working on nanotech robotics ai
sentient weapon creation and now
hayward assigns monica to you know west
view new jersey to
run a drone but really i think he
assigned her to this westview anomaly
for a reason
so what do we think sword is really up
to
what is sword's big mission and did
hayward know more about westview than he
initially led on to monica when he gave
her that assignment
yes everything yes sorry yes to
everything i think he
definitely set her up because like
countless people have already said you
and you especially of why would you send
her on a mission like this
she doesn't need to be sent and if you
guys are truly lacking all of the like
necessary people that you need because
of the blip
why would you send the most important
person on something like this
yeah and then when he was also saying
like we're missing all of these people
i was like what if we're missing the
actual acting director
what if we're missing like actually
oh my god what if we get that scene
sorry i'm screaming but oh my god we'll
probably get that scene we'll probably
get that scene episode
episode seven i'm gonna call it i think
we'll get that scene
it's just in a closet it's in a broom
closet some person is just like
he's feeding them every day yeah oh my
gosh we're gonna get it you heard it
here first folks
you heard it here first the real person
no i think uh
you know i think this guy even lied
about uh maria
rambo saying that i want you to ground
my daughter if she ever comes
like what a weird dying request to make
like if my daughter ever comes back from
this like
seemingly permanent rapture make sure
she doesn't go on any space missions why
would maria do that why wouldn't she
want her daughter to live her dreams in
the stars
he's lying he's a liar okay so i'm gonna
defend that because i think immediately
she comes back i think
like the reason why she's like don't
give her a space mission
because she just came back and she just
found out i'm dead
so i think that that's like a ground as
like you know it's like a mom
thing to do as a thinker are if she
gets in a space cockpit she's just gonna
keep flying
forever into space no it's just like
she's like it's like oh
because she needs to grieve you know she
came back like within my evening's face
i'm like
touch on jessica i totally agree that i
think i don't think that's really tyler
hayward especially since scrolls
was mentioned oh you think he's a scroll
are you doing a scroll search laura
siriqua
i would love hard my heart would soar if
that
happened uh i do i think you're onto
something obviously scrolls are gonna
come up they already have come up they
were on jimmy woo's board
but i i actually think that uh hayward
is like anti-scroll i think he is like
girls like suspicious like he doesn't
trust them and there are other factions
of sort i think maria rambo's faction
was very pro
uh collaboration with scrolls and then
tyler hayward was kind of happy to see
her go
he's like good i'm gonna crack it down
only
only terrans in sword i don't want any
freaking scroll collaborators and then
they get banished to the space station
but he wants only humans actually on
earth
i also defend uh uh tyler here our our
friend here
i think he's head
maybe i misheard that exchange but the
way i always interpret that moment and i
know it seems suspicious that it's only
targeted toward monica
the way i interpret it is this they've
been living through this blip thing
and so i i like the idea that he's
anti-scroll so anyone who just shows up
and says hey i'm monica
it's like you gotta ground anybody who
shows up for six months
and we're gonna run scroll tests on them
just to be sure this is really a person
who got unblipped
so it's not just monica it's anybody i
think that's gonna start getting i agree
with that
the part that makes me nervous is i feel
like it's gonna be doing the same thing
that samuel jackson nick fury was doing
where it's the situation of like
everyone's a bigger threat than us and
we need to make sure we have
a weapon that makes us the biggest
threat so we might be getting that same
storyline again but i like the idea
and i could see that happening of him
being like
too overly cautious and this is what's
gonna slowly go into the scroll
like war that we're gonna see eventually
but
i think there's a reason why um monica
is part of this show
and i think it's because of the scrolls
because her connection with this girl
ivan and we don't know enough about
tyler hayward to know if he's like
entice girl because like there's nothing
that he says he hates uh
extraterrestrial i
i just got that laura from the fact that
like uh she's
he's like oh we're just preparing for
threats you know in outer
space and she's like well there's allies
up there too and he's just kind of like
whatever and i saw this huge eye roll
that the actor didn't really do but he
just didn't have a response he's just
kind of like
uh uh-huh yeah off to new jersey little
one to be fair that actor plays
like the bad guy in a lot of shows
he just has that he just has that
demeanor in that face
yeah he has a dick face face that's all
the opposite of [ __ ] face
i have a wild theory as to what uh tyler
is really doing
and i know this is all i'm gonna be the
odd one out here because i'm not on the
team mephisto i'm on team annihilus okay
and if in the mcu they had say this this
is very complicated not complicated but
they had visions bias they're like and
he's like i want to build my own vision
so they build
nihilus an island goes fu i'm out of
here and so he runs away and he's like
ah
uh so now um his weapon got out and so
that's why they're interested in finding
uh this zone and and then maybe
annihilus is over where uh
wanda and vision are i love annihilus
being part of this i feel like that
would be the
comic uh tie-in that no one saw coming
um yeah but i think like first either
way
i think no matter what we know that like
i don't
we don't know this but it really does
seem like hayward knew what was going on
in west view he had that whole line of
like yeah i know what cmbr is
it's you know real like radiation dating
back to the big bang ba-ba-ba i gotta
get back to hq
like this guy is a bumbling dope when he
keeps sending in drone after drone
person after person in there like this
guy
he's like i think he made some kind of
deal ahead of time he knew what he was
sending monica into so i
he he's pulling some strings maybe not
all the strings
i at least think he might have been
involved with maria's death what do you
guys think about that
is anyone ever dead is anyone ever dead
in there
anyone ever did give me my gold ticket
now
okay so let me finish first
so i think okay so first off
um i think for cinematic reasons for the
writing
yes that would be great for them to
write in if tyler is the villain
he had to have killed maria like also
with all this radiation that's going on
i feel like
i'm not saying this is like a dr
manhattan situation but like
she could have got cancer from this and
he could have been like not supplying it
but orchestrating the amounts that are
coming in
and she's also in space we know that she
found his sword so like let's
that's another thing but um i think she
will
come back and by come back it's she's
gonna be like taunted
in the bubble to monica if monica
breaches the bubble again
um i think monica's now we're getting
she we're recognizing she is like
our protagonist yeah he did have
something to do with her death
story-wise it'll make sense but i also
think she's gonna come back
even if it's for a brief moment of time
i think her like form will come back in
that bubble
i am i am going to award one golden
sparkle book to
laura for the for tightness girls i
don't know if hayward is a squirrel
himself
but i think he his his role in this
is going to be scroll connected for sure
the smiling guy
is a scroll he's smiling
he's totally scrolling yeah we're tying
it all back great those licenses
that's why he made all those licenses no
one will find out
chris for your annihilus theory i'm
giving you a golden sparkle buck as well
and whatever jessica you get one for
saying maria comes back in
uh a form as a taunt like monica
everybody gets one but me i'm the child
in the classroom
[Music]
okay it's this participation trophy
round everyone gets a taste
well uh it is time for us to move on to
our rogue question uh so this is our
question this week i want to hear each
of you answer this
this week lego released a white noise
playlist of just their blocks being
assembled
click click click click what
nerdy noise takes you to your happy
place
why would they do that it works
does it make noise i'm looking around my
room for legos right now
legos gives me anxiety because i'm
always afraid i'm always afraid to do it
the wrong way
so if i hear click click i'm going to be
like is that is that correct did they
put it in the right spot
i have two answers okay one nostalgic
any time that transformer noise goes
blah blah blah
yeah just like a little it's a little
like dope
a little shot of childhood there um and
there's actually a youtube channel that
has this they have 10 hours of the
tardis hum
it feels like you're actually on the
tardis and it would put me right to
sleep
you know what mine is i think because i
took a foley class in college
i'm better than everybody
holy
[Music]
you're such a bottle
um but
my favorite noise was um the star wars
doors opening because it's just a letter
coming out of an envelope just going
swoop so i think that noise if that was
played a lot it's very soothing to hear
that that's really all it was they just
took a letter out of an envelope
that's yeah you want to make fun of me
now you want to make fun of me oh never
again i stand corrected
i'm so glad you took your foley class to
tell me that
oh yeah so yeah i do love that
transformer one but
i do have one that i actually play like
every time i walk in and out of the room
um i have this command badge like it so
when you walk by it it
it sounds of the the start of star trek
doors opening
mm-hmm i really love that like if i
could just i always
like even if i don't need to walk
through the hallway i just walk through
the hallway just so i can hear it
like i walk through and i'm just like
this is so soothing
well the golden sparkle book is gonna go
to jessica for that
just for giving us a nice bit of a star
wars trivia that you probably overpaid
for some class in college
don't even why don't you even say that
you know i did
every college course is overpriced uh
college tuition should be free
it was fun if i would have found that
class i found that class i
kid you not senior year like
winter of senior year if i found that
freshman year i would have been a foley
artist
i would have been like bye you guys are
gonna be a full final what like what was
your final like i had to take off
all the audio of um a scene from the
star
not star wars from the lego movie uh the
first lego movie
and it was the scene where they're like
flying through the copter and then they
go through the moon
and we had to make ev even the voice
over part so i played elizabeth banks
which was i was like
oh god it was but it was really fun
so you have to like you had to release
the muppet doc you now have to
release the latest project the saddest
thing about this
is my terabyte drive from college got
corrupted and i was trying to put this
on my website i kid you guys not i would
i don't mind sharing this
this is the coolest thing i've ever done
in my entire life you'll just have to
recreate it now
yeah you'll have to remake it you have
until tomorrow
i broke like 32 bottles i was like
yeah i'll do that in my bedroom
um well i think i have two points for
each jessica and chris
and so the tie will go to the newcomer
making you chris the winner of this week
of rogue theory
it was a close it was a close match it
was very very close a bunch of great
theories i loved hearing from all three
of you guys
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our guests laura
siricol
uh chris mcgowan and jessica clements
follow all three of them on their
social media platforms show them some
love support their various projects
uh and you can support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options
this is our unusual couple latest
obsession shirt i think we are selling
out of these so you got to jump on there
fast it's a great shirt get it at
newrockstarsmerch.com
uh you can also follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to here
on
new rockstars2 here at here right now
thank you
um also a reminder to download the
stereo app by going to stereo.com
new rockstar so that you can listen to
our three new weekly live shows it's not
just our shows on stereo you can join a
wide range of conversations on topics
like comedy pop culture and sports
download the app for free on apple and
android and create an avatar and profile
be sure to download now so you can
submit questions to one of our upcoming
shows
jessica and i will be there tomorrow
morning at 8 am talking about tonight's
episode of wanda vision
i will see you there and see you all
next time bye loving
bye i'm trying to come up with a new
phrase to say goodbye to
[Music]
you